hello everyone and welcome to the first
game we'll be covering from this year's
norway chess it's alireza ferruccia
versus magnus carlsen and norway chess
this year is it's a six player double
round robin featuring some very strong
players like these two first and carlson
also uh sergey uh karjakin will be
playing yanni ponnichi so the world
church championship challenger will also
have a nice clash between magnus and and
nepo at some point uh richard rapport
and of course uh aryanthari uh the
second norwegian that's playing in this
tournament so uh it's a double round
robin like i said 10 rounds of classical
chess which means two hours for all
moves and they do get an increment but
only starting from move 40 and the
increment is 10 10 seconds per move and
as an extra incentive for this
tournament uh for a win you don't get
the usual two points but actually you
get three points so uh winning is uh
well uh much preferred than you know
just just drawing games
so that being said let's check it out
this is the first one that we're
covering uh and already we have a very
nice surprise starting as of move seven
so already with the white pieces opens
with e4 now we have c5 magnus goes for
his usual sicilian we have knight to f3
knight to c6 and the bishop to b5 uh
going for the iniz medina of rosso limo
attack we have e6 by magnus and here we
have castles by ferruccia knight g to e7
the knight is going to the usual uh g6
square rook to e1 and now knight to g6
we have c3 uh making preparation for
that the d for pushing the in the center
and magnus grabs the center by playing
d5 so every sicilian player's dream uh
and now there are some games in the
database were just e captures and e5 was
played also queen to a4 is a is a known
move but here alireza starts with h4 and
it is now like i said already as of move
7 that we have a completely new game and
the magnus has to evaluate this very
very carefully uh no doubt that this has
been extensively prepared so one thing
it does well other than grabbing more
space on the king side it's preparing h5
which will dislodge the knight and
you're gonna have to figure out where
the knight will go to if you go to f4
then you can play d4 maybe open up an
attack with the bishop so it's
definitely a question you can't go to e5
because just captures this knight will
not be able to help out it's pinned so
magnus has to figure out how to go about
this and well you could go for something
like d captures on e4 uh then we have
rook captures on e4 and now uh it's uh
well how do you continue there's no good
way of challenging this rook here uh you
might continue bishop to d6 but then
white can just straight for example
captures captures played d3 and white is
very happy he uh he doubled black spawns
here yes black does have the bishop pair
but magnus
would uh probably be able to to handle
this however uh he decides to see what
furuja really has prepared and he just
plays a6 he says all right i'm very
interested in your h4 move but first i'm
going to challenge the bishop and now do
you gonna do go back with some like
bishop e2 unlikely bishop to f1 or do
you just capture on c6 and furuja spent
quite a lot of time here as this is a
classical game before deciding to
really capture that knight on c6 so
bishop captures on c6b captures and now
advancing the pawn as planned with h5 so
magnus goes to f4 not worried about this
d4 idea uh so alireza just plays it uh
he played d4 here but there were some
other very interesting options for
example e captures on the five runs into
knight to d3 attacking the rook here and
once you move the rook let's say rookie
three now we can capture the bishop and
now we get this very very exciting
position where the queen could capture
on a1 uh nc1 but even better is queen to
a4 threatening queen captures on c6 so
now queen captures on d5 and now knight
to a3 now this knight will will fall
and white will just have a very
comfortable game if you try and save it
with knight to d3 then you run into
trouble after rook captures on d3 uh for
example queen captures queen captures on
c6 with check and now after the queen
goes back uh we are gonna pick up the
rook on a8 so queen captures an eight
and now we might see a queen trait here
for example queen b7 captures captures
and you get this position where magnus
would have two bishops against two
knights uh but he has uh
three pawn islands uh it is a has two so
it's uh you know it's a very very tricky
position to play the engine prefers
white uh but it's it's hard to say what
would happen here so there is a instead
of something like this it goes for d4
right away opens up an attack against
the knight magnus claims the h5 pawn and
the now knight to e5 putting pressure on
the c6 pawn and the magnus says nope not
a problem of course the queen also
attacks the knight on h5 so knight back
to f6 and now queen to a4 yeah if you go
and hurry up and gobble up the pawn with
knight captures on c6 it's not a very
important pawn it's a double c pawn you
just help black develop we're gonna play
queen to c7 and now what do you play you
can't really go back with the knight
you're gonna have to play e captures on
d5 we're gonna play knight captures on
d5 and now you can play knight back to
e5 for example and black doesn't have a
worry in the world you can easily
develop your dark square bishop the
light square bishop will have this
beautiful diagonal so no no worries for
black here so after knight to f6 we have
queen to a4 now putting more pressure on
c6 and magnus plays bishop to d7 he says
all right if you want to capture it
you're going to have to do it some other
way so bishop to g5
continues playing actively developing
pieces and the bishop to e7 magnus just
you know naturally the
developing pieces saying uh let's see
what do you have so knight captures on
d7 we have queen captures on d7 and now
e5 uh grabbing more space in the center
forcing the knight to move and now while
you could go to e4 magnus just goes back
knight to g8 and now he wants to capture
the bishop with the knight and then he's
gonna have the f5 square available for
his knight so bishop captures an e7
knight captures and now d captures on c5
grabbing back the pawn
but now queen to b7 magnus goes after
this b2 pawn and now b4
uh immediately we have a5 and it's a
it's a very tricky tricky move because
you could capture an a5 but it only
brings trouble for you for example b
captures on a5 we're gonna play queen to
b2 attacking the rook and now white only
has knight to a3 but it's not all that
impressive queen captures on c3 uh the
a5 pawn is attacked twice we're
attacking the c5 pawn we already have it
past the d-pawn uh and if something like
a6 trying to keep an eye on this point
it's a quite a forced variation queen
captures on c5 we're gonna attack the
queen now we're gonna move the queen
attack the pawn twice again now we're
going to play rook captures on c6 trying
to get knight captures and queen
captures with check black would play
queen to d7 now attacking the rook twice
rook 8 to c1 doubling up here and now
just knight captures on c6 we would have
a queen trait for example captures
captures and captures and you get this
position where white is down the
exchange but he kind of has a very
dangerous pawn on a6 all in all black
should not have a lot of trouble
defending this for example king 37
attacks the real quick d6 tricking e7
and now if knight to b5 uh now what do
you play here uh well you bring the
other rook into the game of course
you're gonna play rook h the d8 trying
to get the trade in rook to b6 and now
uh only now do we play rook to b8 now
forcing a trade the knight is on b5 and
after something like captures captures
a7 uh rook to a8 easily stops the pawn
and there is really no hope for white
here so this is of course with perfect
play but uh the idea stands uh so
alireza goes back queen to b3 now he
wants some uh a4 maybe b5 action in the
future
and magnus just castles we have castles
here and not knight to d2 continuing
development and alireza spent quite a
lot of time uh in this opening
considering he's the one who who
prepared h4 he's already down to 29
minutes on the clock whereas magnus has
some one hour and 10 minutes on the
clock uh and here we have queen to a6
uh so what do you what do you play here
well an interesting try would definitely
be a4 like we mentioned and then maybe
preparing b5 to get a pass pawn in black
would play something like rook after b8
and the game continues but alireza has a
different plan he just continues with
knight to f3 now the knight is coming to
d4 uh going to put pressure on that uh a
weak c6 pawn and magnus just offers a
queen trade so queen to c4 uh and now
already i didn't uh spend a lot of time
here but magnus kind of did it is only
spent like one minute whereas magnus is
now down to 55 minutes so after
considering the position for uh some
time already decided to trade queens as
there really isn't anything better we
have d captures and now rook to e4 going
after that c4 pawn magnus captures on b4
we have c captures on b4 and now rook to
a4 preparing to double up on the a file
firuja picks up the c4 pawn and now rook
f2a8 so now you will win this pawn
there's no question about it
and now knight to d4 now kind of
paralyzing this knight because if you
move it the c6 pawn falls so here we
have a nice capture fest rook captures
on a2 rook captures rook captures and
now b5 uh
threatening to to create a pass pawn
here so magnus has to trade and now we
play knight captures on b5 and this is
resulting position alireza and the
magnus equal in material both a rook and
item four pawns uh but alireza has a
past c pawn so how can magnus prevent
this pawn from advancing well knight to
c6 it's important to block the pawn we
have knight to d4 now offering a trade
and now knight captures on d4 we have
rook captures and now i know you guys
really want to put a rook behind the
pass pawn but if you do this then the
rook to d8 is checkmate so we have to do
something about that first magnus plays
king to f8 and only now we have uh
c6 by furuja uh you might again be
thinking why not rook to c4 there's
nothing wrong with it the rook
definitely deserves to be behind the
past pawn but it's not uh nothing
dangerous let's say king e7 c6 we're
going to block the pawn king the 8th c7
king c8 and now you could attack those
king side pawns for example g6 rook to
f4 okay you will win this pawn but just
rook to c2 and black is very happy here
rook captures an f7 rook captures on c7
rook f6 going after the pawn just king
d7 and again equal material there's
there will be no winners here so instead
after this king to f8 we have c6 right
away by alireza and now rook to c2 we
have rook to d8 with check king to e7
and now rook to d7 with check as
carlson's king cannot go anywhere other
than the the back rank and uh you have
to go to
uh to
e8 if you go to f8 then you lose the
game of course c7 and there's no defense
check followed by queening is coming so
of course magnus played the king
king to e8 uh and al reza just played
rook to c7 and he was in this position
on move 35 that they agreed to a draw as
there is nothing to be done here and
they both know it uh so let me just
check something really quickly
uh there we go
in just a second
yeah no that's it it really was in this
position that the day that they drew the
game i stopped watching the live
coverage and then i me maybe a few more
moves were played but uh the uh you know
they weren't uh this is where where they
ended the game and as this is a double
round rob and they will face each other
again magnus will have the white pieces
and we'll see if
we'll be able to defend with black but i
know you guys are waiting for a very
specific round so to tell you which
round that will be uh carlson is playing
uh against uh niepo uh
in round uh four and then again of
course in round eight so just as i know
this is the the clash that all of you
are waiting for uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it uh try
preparing something very special with
that new movie h4 magnus defended well
there really wasn't anything going on
there we've seen that uh some of the
variations were really crazy and alireza
definitely prepared for them at home but
magnus uh uh just avoided all of them
and traded down into this uh
uh end game and fairu didn't really give
him any opportunities uh to exploit uh
uh
in this very nice line that he prepared
uh so that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it we're gonna keep covering
this tournament uh as
uh there are more games to be seen uh
nipple versus karakin did not happen
today their game will be finished at
some other point i don't know why i was
delayed probably someone had
some some problems but i will keep you
guys informed so once again hope you
guys enjoyed it i would like to thank
happy birthday uh happy 40th birthday
nemo uh david marcus john roberts f
lightheart and suas raja chandragupta
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot to really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank all for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this very nice tournament
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world thank you all i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day